Christmas isn't getting any cheaper food
price is one of the main things pushing
up inflation
and with places like this Farm Shop
seeing their margins squeeze there may
be more increases to come our biggest uh
cost pressure is electricity now we
because obviously we've got lots of
refrigeration and we're very reliable
electricity I mean through the summer
also it's very hot so we're using lots
more than normal
this weather is not so bad but we're
I've still seen a increase of nearly
three thousand pound a month for my
electricity bill which is a massive pill
to swallow come the New Year obviously
we're gonna have to look where we can
cut back in all directions you know um
obviously you feel as a matter of fact
so there's only so much you can put on
prices you know your customers are all
struggling as well in the face of this
inflation the bank of England raised
interest rates for the ninth successive
meeting a new record taking them up to
3.5 percent when we looked at your
previous mortgage higher rates are
already squeezing those with mortgages
Andy is paying an extra 750 pounds a
month those that do have a mortgage
you've got a bit of a bit of a double
whammy there they're getting the
increase in in mortgage rates or base
rates but also much less disposable
income in terms of trying to service
their other bills or afford the other
things that they've got in their life as
well the bank describes some small
glimmers of Hope inflation's probably
peaked and the recession might not be as
deep as feared but the squeeze is likely
to get worse before it gets better we've
had the highest inflation since it's the
1980s the biggest increase in interest
rates over a year since the 1980s we've
got the most widespread industrial
action since the 1980s it's no
coincidence this is all happening at the
same time we're living through a
convergent interlocking set of crises
where everyone is getting worse off but
the public sector's point is they are
getting worse off quicker than everyone
else why because private sector earnings
are rising far faster than those of
state workers something the governor
reiterated the earnings numbers took in
the private sector coming out a bit bit
above where we thought there would be
not a lot above I don't want to put too
much uh emphasis on on the scale of the
uh in the sense of the overshoot but
they are coming out a bit above where we
thought they would be
but that is really consistent with the
fact that the labor market in this
country is so tight
many of those striking including these
postal workers in Hertfordshire so it's
unfair that their real earnings are
falling back the government argues that
to give them higher pay would risk
letting inflation get out of control
this argument is likely to rage all the
way to Christmas and Beyond at Conway
Sky News